what's up everybody this is mike of
munch development coming to you with
another coding tech
original today we're going to be
discussing 10
helpful vs code extensions for
javascript
alright so without further ado let's get
started all right so you see i've got my
main.js over here
and you can see it's all over the place
with the formatting right so how can i
fix this there
is there anything that i can do well
absolutely yes
i'm going to install our first extension
and you're probably very familiar with
it i talked about it on the last
video it's prettier all right prettier
for the win
i'm going to enable this okay and then
i'm going to go into settings and
command
comma i'm going to make sure that format
on save
is enabled and it is i'm going to come
back here and i'm going to
just click save and voila right now it's
obviously opinionated you see here
it uh it brought the brackets up so it's
opinionated about
where the bracket should be it should be
on the same line as the function or on
the the next line
uh it also is opinionated about
semicolons out of the box
uh it also is uh opinionated about line
length right so it's gonna
when i save that it brings this down
here it's also opinionated about
uh and it should be about whether like
where if
nesting of if statements right so you
see when i save it does that
right um again all of this is
customizable so you can go into the
prettier settings
and change it it's also opinionated
about single and double quotes right so
if i were to change this to single
quotes
here when i save it it's going to make
it double quotes right
so again you go in and you set those
settings up on your own
um but prettier if you're trying to
format your code uh
format it on save to get rid of all of
the you know the guesswork
as to did i put this on the right line
and put it you know prettier for the win
go
go for it right all right so bracket
pair colorizer number two bracket pair
colorizer all right
so before i enable it and this is
bracket pair colorizer 2
all right you see here all of my
brackets and all of my parens
are white right now there's nothing
wrong with that
right if they want to be white they can
be white let them just stay that way
but for my eyes i'd like to see
something a little bit different that
helps me to
uh figure out where like what's closing
what
okay and that's what bracket color
bracket pair colorizes so the prayer the
ending in the beginning bracket are
going to be the same color
all right so let's install that enable
it you go over here you can install it
you would have that green button there
i just have it in the enable button
because it's already installed on my
machine
so i'm going to enable it and then i'm
going to reload
and the defaults gonna be gold orchid
and light sky blue right
all right you can tell i've done a
couple of takes of this right so
you can go and then you can change that
information though right so gold
uh you see the uh the orchid and then
light sky blue
right so all of these are now changed
where the light sky blue is one of them
down there there it is
that that closing uh parens is light sky
blue alright
so you can change all of that in your
settings right here right bracket pair
colorizer two colors
right first two three you can just
change them you can add them
right so you can do that to your heart's
content whatever looks good to your eye
right you change it up all right so
number three
is in dent rainbow now let me show you
what life
is like before indent rainbow what it's
going to change all right you see this
little
uh section right here where it's uh that
little lines going down there
right and then that color in between is
all black right you can see
right what's closing what and then again
you have the disclosure triangle that
where you can you know open it and close
it right um
but what indent rainbow does and you'll
see immediately is that it
turns this into sort of a little pyramid
right a rainbow
of uh things that you can see like i
could say okay now i can look straight
down and see that that same color goes
with that color that goes with that with
that with that right
and it's doing that for all of them okay
so when you have nested
and again this is a simple javascript
file but when you have a more complex
javascript let's
let's say you're working in angular or
reactor view and you've got you know
many things nested
it gets very it's very helpful to see
this visually
to know where the line goes down all
right so
number four is to do highlight all right
let me
oh let's do that there you go to do
highlight okay so you see i've got one
to do and one fix me in here now these
are comments and i can just
like well i don't really care i'm gonna
pass this up because my eye's not drawn
to that that's just a comment
who cares all right well not with to do
highlight you'll have to work
to with the default colors let's show
you what i'm talking about
you have to work to ignore these two all
right you see that right that's pink
and that's bright that's bright orange
all right
so to do highlight again as in
everything uh to
do right to do highlight you can uh
where it
just ran away from me okay it had its
own thing so
you can look at certain things you can
um in the in the settings you can change
the colors
uh let's see where is that yeah default
style
well if you can go into the yeah default
exclude no modules
uh i think you can change the colors i'm
not mistaken i'm pretty sure
but you can go into the settings and and
check on that yourself right so include
case sensitive enabled keywords
yeah i'm pretty sure there's a way to
change the colors in there
but uh just go check out the
documentation but to do highlight
uh is amazing it helps you to see
visually i've got work to do right so
need to make this line shorter well i
did that by installing prettier so i can
get rid of that one yeah to did
to did all right so all right so uh and
then you get you got this fix me here
right react is not a framework
how dare you right react is a library
how dare i
okay uh so you can change that i i have
to fix that right so whenever i'm up
here i need to have a conditional that
says if the framework is equal to react
then just use library instead of
framework okay all right so
number five number five version lens now
to enable version lens i've got to do a
couple of things i've got to create an
npm project all right so i'm gonna do no
package manager npm uh
init initialize minus y accept all the
defaults
okay and then i'm gonna need to install
all right a couple of packages so i'm
gonna do axios
common you know well known well no low
dash
another well known i probably could have
installed momentum let me just install
moment right install cause that'll help
later on for something else that i'm
gonna show you all
all right so uh so version lens all
right so let's go
let's look it up version lens that is
number five all right version lens okay
so we're going to open up our
package.json file
all right so we've got our three there
right so let's let's enable version lens
and see what it gives us
all right so version lens i do not up
there it is right up there at the top
you see that
show dependency versions all right so
i'm going to click it
okay so now look this is telling me that
i'm at the latest right there so i've
got the latest of all of these three
so let's say if you were an older let's
let's look at this let's see if i had
that and i saved it
it satisfies right so you see what
changed it satisfies
0.20 but the latest is this so i can
also click it and
it'll update it right inside of my
package.json and says
so now if i if i install it it's going
to install the latest version
okay so that's just a visual real quick
visual
to let you see okay well in my
package.json and my
are any of my packages out of date and
can i install them
right uh i'll update them okay so it's a
visual cue
for that all right and i really like it
all right i really like that it's
something i'm always using
okay because i go back to my old code a
lot i'm like okay this is breaking wire
well it's probably because
you you install something new or that
doesn't work with something older all
right
so let's go to number six all right
number six
is import cost import cost
okay uh import cost before i
install it i'm gonna do something really
quickly so i'm going to install
i'm going to um bring in those three
libraries that i installed all right so
moment equals require whoops not request
moment all right and i'm going to say
give me those three
i want to say low dash all right low
dash and then i also want was the other
one axios
and axios dot default
okay so and then i save it you see what
happened just like wait a minute
it fixed everything for me okay so right
now i'm looking at this and it's like
well they're really you know
great thanks you i know what i know how
to use these things i can put them in
there and i know
i'm not using them right now but what
does the import cost show me let's
enable it and let's see what happens all
right you see what it's doing
it's calculating the amount of space
that i'm going to use when i import this
right it's it's calculating it's like
okay
well you're using 71. oh it's like look
at moment like
that's red right do i wanna do i really
wanna use moment
right do i wanna use low dash because is
there any way that i could
you know if i need specific things let's
see if i just needed pick
from low dash what would that change
anything uh if i just you know if axios
is is okay right um if i just
i was like okay if i want omit like what
could i do to just pull off
certain things how could i how could i
make this a little bit less expensive
so you get to make those decisions right
when you're actually in
um you know in the weeds and discussing
um
what libraries you want to use you can
look at import costs and import costs
will help you to make
wise decisions as to which libraries to
use right
to that moment moment look at you moment
is
is a beast all right so you got the red
right and i think there's probably a way
to go into your settings
and uh let's look at let's see import
cost all right so there's no settings is
that even more settings
we'll see i mean let's just look in here
and see because you may be able to say
you know what uh so yeah default import
yeah
and it does all of them right so it uses
um any of these
it lets you right so it supports
javascript and typescript
i'm not sure about the settings uh small
package size okay that's what i was
looking for right
so a medium package size would be 50k so
you can set these things okay
i figured you could all right and then
you want to you can set the colors to
let you know like okay this is what i'm
looking for and you can set your ignores
okay
cool so i hadn't done it i was just
using the defaults but
you know i mean yeah this is pretty this
is pretty good just out of the box all
right
so the next thing that we're going to
use is something we've already used
before but i'm going to cheat a little
bit because we use it in the html css
is get lens right because it's not the
it's not only in html css that we need
this all right so let me initialize
an empty get project uh get i want to do
a get
ad well let's make sure i do get oh
touch dot get ignore ignore
all right and then i'm gonna open up the
get ignore i get ignored and then i'm
going to add no modules to it right
no modules because we do not want that
going up right so you see it goes from
from a thousand plus to 10. all right so
now i'll do a git add dot
do a git commit minus m initial
commit all right and
okay so what we should get with git lens
well we haven't installed it yet
but that's i just did i had to do that
to do that basic like first commit thing
all right
so let me enable get lens all right and
it's going to read the application
and you see what happens now it looks
like look at that look at that guy there
ha ha look at him yeah look at that
fella
all right so it shows you who just who's
who's the person
that um that made this last commit all
right you can click their profile you
can go and take a look at it
um yeah you can click it and just go and
say oh look at that guy well i'm not
doing that or you can email them okay
and just tell them how much you don't
like them
all right but you can also click on the
commit and i think that's gonna go to
yeah
all right so we did that last time right
it shows you what was committed all
right
so you get to see all of that
information with get lens i love
get lens all right like if you're using
git
get lens okay so let's move to number
eight and nine they're like a double dip
okay a double dip all right so debugger
for chrome
all right so we're gonna do that and
we're gonna install it
all right so if you're used to debugging
pack uh your applications
right in chrome or firefox because i'm
gonna do that one too
i'm gonna enable both of them all right
so i have i'm gonna go live
uh with this html all right and i'm
gonna
let's go over here let's see i think i
have it already
uh running there it is okay great
all right let me clear let me clear the
console there
all right so it's already running all
right so in my
uh i want let's just say right here i
want to
uh when i get to this line i'm going to
set that as a breakpoint okay
so i'm going to come over here and i'm
going to click run so i'm going to click
launch in chrome all right so i've
installed
the debugger now so i'm launching it in
chrome i'm gonna click play
and then when i come to yes i should
all right wait let's see require is not
defined
oh duh that's because i'm not in
i'm not in uh node.js right
all right so you have to go back to
browser stuff all right so
okay so you see we've got our it's
paused in debugger right it's telling
you that same thing so you can see over
here
and over here it's doing the same thing
right you got a lot of so
all but but what happens is you can stay
inside of
chrome oh you can stay inside of visual
studio code now
because you've got chrome developer
tools uh set so i can just walk
i can step into this i can look at it i
can say okay what's my call stack over
here
right you've got a lot of stuff did you
oh look at my numbers and i'm in my call
stack my call stack is just one up with
the square
right i've got all of my local variables
i've got my go global execution context
over here
uh what what's on the global threads my
functions are on the global
global execution context i got my
subtract all right inside of the script
you guys so
i've got all of that information that i
would have in chrome now i've got it
right here in visual studio code
i don't have to go anywhere right i can
just stay right here all right
so let's do that again let's do that in
firefox because that's
number what's that with number eight
yeah let's hold on one second let me
just go back
all right yeah that was number eight
number nine is firefox right so i'm just
gonna
the new firefox and do the same thing
and hit play and it should open up in
firefox
and let's see firefox there it is all
right
so it's in it's opened up in firefox did
i stop let me reload it refresh there it
is all right
so now it's open in firefox and we're
doing the same stuff launched in firefox
and we can we can walk through it
uh let's look at the debugger over here
in firefox you should
see yeah let's see break points and
watches
all right let's do that we're going to
walk through walk through walk through
walk through
okay there it is all right let's see
where's the where's the call stack over
here is that the right one
am i looking at the right one i believe
so all right let's see sources outline
well maybe it just maybe it uh takes it
over and when i launch it
over here right all right but you see
it's actually running the code
so uh that's yeah that's that's uh
debugger for chrome and firefox and
number 10
is probably one of my favorite recent uh
plug-ins all right it's pro that's it's
so amazing
right it's it's helped me to get rid of
other applications which shall
remain nameless right because i'm not
here to disparage anyone
but uh this one is called
rest client okay rest client
all right so i'm gonna enable this and
i'm gonna open up
uh the file that i created over here
called routes
dot rest all right now
look at this all right come on y'all
like this is amazing
you click i just have this is a exchange
little exchange
uh currency exchange thing that i did i
just installed the uh
yeah install it to heroku instance i
click send request
all right let's see come on work for me
now do i need to reload
let's stop let me reload the environment
make sure that
this works all right because i have to
this one is so nice
i have to yeah all right so five minutes
ago i'm the one that did that so let's
see
send request all right there it is okay
so i did the tippy uh
jsonplaceholder.typical.com and post
and you see what what came over here i
just click send request
and look at that man i've got the post
right
all right so let's do that again right
so i can put multiple requests in the
same
um in the same file so if i just want
post 50
right boom post 50 i'm clicking you know
if i want to add a post
right i added a post right i just put
post in front
instead of you know just as assumes gets
it assumes get
but then you can use the same thing with
posts like these i just type this is
just this is just a text file
right in visual studio code but using
that this amazing plug-in rest client
all right so i just updated this one
like hey the darth vader surprise
luke guess who's tall dark handsome and
your father
all right so that's darth vader's
surprise all right so
yeah man like this is this one is
amazing like and i'll do yeah okay so
hit send request
right and you get the all of the um the
the
you know the currency exchange exchange
rates at this exact moment
but rest client is a game changer right
you get to click you know right here in
your file you get to
just type in your you know your request
url and it even it even supports
uh graphql right uh let leo let's see um
i know i haven't done any i haven't done
anything with it yet
but uh it it actually supports i think
if you look at the um
so making a graph obviously because the
graphql um
request is just a post request right so
yeah you can do it you just send in the
the you know
the query of the mutation you can do
whatever you need to do
right but yeah it does support it uh so
let's see where is it
yeah request headers i mean the
documentation is extensive
this is probably one of the best oh man
this is one of like give a shout out to
huacho
who who chow mao right mao
like that guy needs like some hand clap
some
some love from the open source community
because this is a game changing
i can't stop singing these phrases right
i'm gonna probably shut up so i can just
like shorten this video
but i'm gonna end that's number 10 right
okay so
uh don't forget to like comment and
subscribe to uh to the channel if you
haven't already
uh you'll find a link to the um to the
code um
on github in the description uh again
tell us what you'd like to see next
um you know comment let us know uh what
it is
uh we can do better to help uh serve you
uh thanks again for
tuning in to the coding tech uh youtube
channel i have been your host mike
at munch development and i'll see you on
the next one all right
happy coding